here's how I sell a Klein bottle
somebody goes to my website buys a
bottle comes down into my office I print
out a receipt and a packing slip okay
let's send it out
this has nothing to do with mathematics
everything with running a home business
whoever buys a Klein bottle from me I
figure I'm going to meet them they're
going to bump into me and so I'm going
to make sure that when they when they
see me
I hope they'll be my friend okay
somebody's ordered a Klein bottle ask my
robot robot delivers a box of bottles I
bring it over here I go weigh it step
one take a picture of it
all these mathematicians are smiling at
it weather permitting I'm going to walk
outside
take a picture of the guy against the
sky
against whatever is blossoming whatever
leaves there are
how about hey
okay come on in just bet all of what a
minute walking through the garden and oh
wait a second ah check this out fall
color is here
again why am I going to do this
has nothing to do with mathematics it's
because
if somebody buys a Klein bottle I
celebrate by
walking through our little backyard
garden come on back in let's wrap this
up
well bubble wrap not yet out the door
but hey
here's what's coming
laughs
almost getting there
first before we pack everything up
throw in some sheets of unimportant
information a calibration decal runs
from 0.0 milliliters all the way up to
zero hundred to zero thousand
milliliters start some bubbles come on
Mr machine
foreign
it's a bottle it's a glass bottle that I
hope means fragile
Mr fragile or maybe Miss fragile or Mrs
fragile or fragile them fragile
pictures they're for two purposes
purpose one
is to fix my mistakes if I forgot
something if I screwed up it shows up in
the camera
the other thing therefore is to send to
my customer I say you've put lots of
Automation in place in various ways but
it still seems like a really
time intensive Purpose with all the
handwritten messages and the drawings
really it's time intensive
it's a labor of love
I can't say I make the glass bottles
myself at my age I'm tired of burning my
fingers
and they didn't do that much anyway
but everything else
um packing them making sure that it's
going to the right person
making sure that
it's not going to break along the way
how often do they break
how often does do my Klein bottle spray
in the post in the poll in the post
um
about
one in 200 1 in 300 is broken on
delivery I mean
of course you know if I take it like
this
uh my floor is cushioned so I'm not
worried about it breaking on my floor
but I'm also not worried about
when I first started putting these in
boxes I chose the box and I chose the
method of cushioning them
by taking by going to a stepladder in
standing five feet about a meter and
three quarters off a concrete on top of
concrete dropping them from a ladder
first on that end
than throwing it up like this and
letting it drop a lot of times
you know
you know over and over again well on
here this is a cushiony floor but I did
it over concrete needless to say I also
guarantee these blind bottles you know
if it arrives broken
I'll replace it immediately
in fact one thing I say is look
I want you to be happy
I want my customer to be smiling so if
it breaks in the first three months
send me a picture of the broken thing
send me 10 bucks
I'll replace it
is my little forklift robot to go pick
Klein bottles from stock tilt the thing
if you look carefully at it let's see if
I actually
show this
I mean this is just Homebrew this is
only incidental this is not Klein
bottles it's how to run a warehouse
really